well danish police say several people
have been hit with gunshots at a
shooting in a shopping mall in
copenhagen one person has been arrested
and authorities say they're working to
get a full view of the situation a short
while ago we spoke to steve hinrap who
was in the shopping center when it
happened
take a look at this
um i saw people running away from
tomorrow
um we thought that we it was some fans
that were seeing harry styles we were
supposed to
have a concert in
half an hour so
but
after some time the cops came ambulance
and the
firemen came
and and steve the pictures that we're
seeing now
you recorded them um tell us a bit about
the response once you realize that this
was uh this was a shooting
yeah i went outside to uh reception
and and i asked i asked what was
happening and some said if there was a
shooting
yeah
and it's uh
it's important to say are you safe at
this at this moment are you okay you and
your family
yeah me and me and my wife are in the
room there are some people outside now
one hour ago that it was not allowed to
go outside but there are some people
outside now
there's a helicopter flying around
so you were told to to stay inside um
the hotel
and um
i mean the pictures that we're seeing
look very very
chaotic
have you been inside the the shopping
mall today
what was the atmosphere like
was it yeah we were in
we went the mall like um
half an hour ago before the shooting
happened inside
so we just got to the hotel from the
mall
and we heard that there's the shooting
inside
steve was the shopping mall quite busy
um
when you were there
there were many people inside and it was
normal
people shopping and eating in the
restaurants
there were there were a lot of people
inside
and how do you feel steve knowing that
you're just a few meters from
where something
quite horrific has happened
um
it feels
unreal
we
almost came back to the mall right
before the shooting happened not knowing
there was a shooting
okay so steve we got lucky
our europe correspondent shaform robbins
is in berlin at sketchy details of
course coming out but what's the very
latest
yeah absolutely terrifying scenes being
confirmed there in copenhagen according
to police they tweeted around half past
six local